pour soulever un problème à mon avis le
problème de l'élection présidentielle ou
des que c'est un moment magique etc
mais plus personne n'y croit ça vous
pensez que les chansons à l'ifas courait
depuis le temps que l'on qui se font
avoir par l'élection présidentielle on
leur vend des tas de choses on leur vend
à nouveau monde
les transformations de la france chaque
fois c'est pareil mais les français et
finissent par ne plus croire dont il
voulait définissent par s'abstenir ou
alors ils voient même sens me sens
vraiment y croire
avec quel pourcentage des rôles tant le
maquereau a été je crois que c'est même
pas toujours 13 % compte tenu de la
création et marine le pen elle faisait
complice % de l'électorat
donc je pense qu'il ya un vrai les
lâches partagent à peu votre avis la
vraie régulièrement de l'opinion les
gens les réélections magique personnes y
croire dans la vie sauf quelques cas
calé quelques naïfs mais c'est fini tout
ça et je pense que justement l'élection
présidentielle pose un vrai problème
c'est à dire que sur une élection
présidentielle se prononcent sur un
personnage un personnage c'est très
facile de manipuler une image de
quelqu'un à travers quelques à travers
une image télévisuelle à travers une
manière de le modifier ou de le
magnifier
moi je trouve que c'est complètement
aberrant d'avoir une élection
présidentielle qui terror les autres
élections notamment l'élection
législative alors que lors d'une
législative en principe en parle d'un
programme la partie des potées parti
présidentiel on parle d'une personne
je crois que la démocratie française en
train de crever à cause de sa cause de
l'élection présidentielle telle qu'elle
est vécue aujourd'hui c'est à dire qu'on
vende des personnages aux français un
mouvement notamment l'ordre des
savonnettes et tu cours ne parlent plus
ils sont des problèmes
problème le chemin ensemble la
désindustrialisation la crise sanitaire
le lait les laisser dans l'histoire on
en parle plus aux élections parce que on
parle de personnages avant tous ces
personnages évidemment un programme
éthique
ce sont des gadgets on va supprimer la
taxe d'habitation où on va on va faire
on crée on va recréer le service
militaire s'est toujours pas fait
d'ailleurs le service national
donc ça se joue sur les gadgets à ce
jour des images et non plus sur un vrai
débat de société
moi je regrette vraiment que cette
élection présidentielle est déjà tel
point dénaturer
[Musique]